mas eu mesmo fazer com o avançado
eu vou falar numa função ainda
silenciosa mas que está acontecendo
e essa resolução ao contrário de muitas
outras no passado
nossa centralizava esta função é
permitida quando nós criar algo
diferente criar um projeto um produto
uma iniciativa
nós muitas vezes não inventor e
eventualmente o empreendedor
isso é possível porque nós hoje temos
novas ferramentas
a impressora 3d por exemplo ali presente
de referir que uma das filhas estrelas
aqui na van de geer clientes é é também
uma das firmas estrelas nesta área a
nível global com erros ecossistemas
estão a criar os chamados ex-países a os
clientes calmas e também as
infraestruturas financiamento
o calçamento a e dessa infraestrutura e
vou falar como o estádio é assim a
criança no terminal aéreo de sistemas e
robótica disse que nós estamos numa nova
no início de uma nova revolução
industrial em que a tendência as camas
novas câmeras trata de passar a dimensão
das passarelas nos mercados nomeadamente
o é
são lendas são exigidas novas
competências
há essencialmente essa revolução está em
marcha dentro e eu devo fazer isso há um
personagem chamado michel que quase
brincar cria uma casa em 1998 como fazer
quase tudo como fazer quase tudo foi
final do período que nós hoje estamos a
viver como parte fundamental dessa
função
nós temos que criar novas competências
ano em cima e foi isso que nilson maciel
fez estimou o pensamento divergente deu
a possibilidade a qualquer instante
criar um projeto por mais loucos a
primeira câmera uma rapariga criou
máquinas gritos
nós já estávamos há um espaço interior
ninguém ouvia seus passos triano que
gravamos um botão e sem um grito a deu a
possibilidade de cruzar os alunos a
pensar para os próprios alimentos a
longa história de projetos na não é
assim uma forma geral nós nos
interrogarmos quantas cadeiras
tivemos em que tivemos pensar de ver
gente meu parto as câmeras são
convergentes e por isso é necessário
estimular os alunos a encontrar
problemas e soluções
mas sobretudo é necessário inspirá los e
criar as paixões que organizem a vida e
essa é a verdadeira meta a doença sim
nós passamos tempo estão em alimentos
complicados ea distribuímos partido em
várias direções nós criamos uma
revolução interna uma solução
centralizada
antes tínhamos todas as pessoas da
empresa a criar este ambiente invenção
alguns cantores criarem novas idéias de
ouvir em protótipos criarem vídeos irem
para campanhas criança nem desvios
este ano vários toda essa experiência
para as escolas nós começamos em várias
escolas e temos um grupo só uma pequena
escola há 15 anos como estudo do kit do
sexto dos seis anos que fizerem
experimentamos exatamente isso temos a
liberdade a sair daí eu sou vamos que
criaram a para que elas possam ir
sozinhos outros decidiram transformar o
muro paulo a do cartão num show com
informação digital a outros e ainda que
tá aí pra apps como por exemplo a gravar
os sons que o pai faz durante o sono e
fazer uma síntese manhã a abrigar ações
na maior parte dos casos
e esta é uma iniciativa em procuramos
ensinar aos estudantes um alvo a pensar
de forma divergente e pronto também
criadas as paixões que um dia
desorganizaram devidas para nós
khalfan day é facto um momento
fundamental nesta função da
possibilidade das pessoas todo lado a
contribuírem para que um produto um
projeto uma iniciativa a a aulas do dia
a nós criamos usado já tivemos duas
campanhas de calçado em roma para um
drone aquáticos outra a para uma
plataforma aqui é compatível com arduino
inclusive eletrônica e impressa de
criciúma forma
desta forma parece extremamente
complicado mas de uma forma mais simples
e extremamente ambiciosa e randy
estamos a falar do ego no século 20 eo
preto basicamente nós através do qual
fazem percebemos com muito poucos
recursos é possível aaa a ter uma
instituição global é possível
desenvolver uma comida de apoiantes no
fundo fazemos nós estamos gratos e
depois e ainda não talvez o mais
importante mas é a ser muito
significativo para qualquer empresa a
usp ainda o financiamento quando um dos
seminários em escolas da nota sobre isso
nós sempre esse exemplo este é o custo é
um produto que conseguiu mais três
milhões do que está
é um clube que tem uma bateria é um
clube que tem uma uma coluna de som que
nos permite ficar e ele ouvir a música
que temos eventualmente está o nosso
telemóvel
nós podemos juntar um mostrador não anda
estou certo que muitas pessoas nestas
alan conseguiriam ter esta ideia e
desenvolver um produto com estas
características
muitos dos meus planos em várias câmeras
então ele veio exatamente a esse nível
isso prova que é possível a qualquer
pessoa um dia criar um produto com este
impacto mas conseguiram mais 3 milhões
tiveram 62 mil placas e por isso existe
a hipótese inicial de qualquer pessoa
transformar uma ideia um produto
com o impacto local regional e neste
caso ângulo ao veículo o princípio os
principais veículos ainda em causa andem
são o que estava ligando em portugal nós
hoje temos também o peão e essas
estatísticas são frentes o que está num
dado ano são lançados cerca de mil
projetos nas mais variadas áreas de
criança porque há duas áreas que a acção
estranhamento conhecidas aquelas que
estão orientadas por ciclistas e outras
postulantes a cerca de 30% dos projetos
são bem sucedidos o número muito
reduzido com seus mais de 1 milhão a nós
temos dois projetos aprende o foi um
caso em que os mais três dias
conseguimos a verba quito - 20 mil
herança de conseguir cerca de 80 mil
novas ameaças ao violão e os riffs vamos
conseguir 127 mil e foi um processo de
treinamento difícil eu estou convicto
que um dia todos os cantos da medicina
desviados até do ensino secundário fará
uma campanha da fifa nem nada mais
importante para perceber um momento e
ouviu de um dos nós percebemos nos
próximos dois vídeos são diferentes dos
projetos
em primeiro lugar os riffs e em segundo
use fios basicamente parton sony que nós
temos que olhar sem respirar por alguém
aqui na van
o nível a vida da bateria pascual que
nos diz que é necessário para para o
para termos não falei com a minha amada
nos rios e nós achamos pro futuro em que
nós temos que ir atrás de três mil a 10
mil metros de profundidade no mar para a
pelo menos não utilizar as riquezas que
existem no nosso oceano são necessários
submarinos e por isso nós criamos essa
ideia como viam via tantos milhares de
pequenos submarinos a mil euros
fazer essa exploração para nós mas
queremos criar nosso menino com o
primeiro produto esta fina que a
gasolina
acabamos fazendo alguma menos ambiciosos
os riffs andradina 4 que eu peço pra
passar o primeiro vídeo
se esses de fast a gente fala do pai
basicamente inspiramos nos neurônios até
arranque ea e colocamos isso é estranho
que é a popular por um telemóvel osmar
sangue sem uma câmera é um dos pontos é
importante disse richa que todos os não
fãs com orçamentos muito limitados
quando a maior parte das campanhas das
empresas não só deu ainda os exemplos
que os cestinhas foram simples fato de
todos a todos por são empregados ao
cobrador da empresa ou família antes
filhos filhas clima simples assim por
diante nós no caso dos edifícios
vamos fazer também uma edição que para
essa comunidade mexicanos a perfazer
graus não só a 4 mas também o segundo
vídeo entrou como vices é uma pretende
ser uma plataforma eletrônica e impressa
que é compatível com a bwin quer fazer
um programa mas a associar nos setor
várias firmas que produzem as empresas
baterias impressas ascensores impresso e
tentarmos dar vida objeto 3d permitindo
às pessoas criar em drogas e não pela
casa a possibilidade fazer o arroz como
típicas a possibilidade das pessoas que
fundam não virei a animação do salto e
perfazendo a situações destas do ifs
neto para a publicação a neste caso com
a namorada ou ainda controlado dramas
como este caso nós de fato pessoal
estamos nesta encruzilhada sobre o
futuro ea todos esses problemas
partidárias
carlos martins que foi uma das pessoas
que permitiu a guimarães ser capital
europeia da cultura
dizia dois anos a monte mor no fórum do
trabalho esteve presente em portugal nós
temos sempre esta visão ultra central
sala nós vamos salvar portugal com as
autoras
nós vamos salvar a portugal com
assistências
vamos salvar portugal construindo
auto-estradas e fato o uso de farelo e
fateh altura nós olhamos promover o
completamente distintos de
desenvolvimento
aí o meu país viram não deu indicativos
nós temos um modelo de infecção quando
somos todos infectados durante as aulas
depois estamos a infecção nos testes nos
anos a nós precisamos de alguém curar as
que nós a ser um evento todos nós temos
que olhar para um modelo econômico uma
forma não tradicional e olhar para as
possibilidades que os clientes calmas
anos abrem
dessa forma nós teremos uma capacidade
de geração distribuída da riqueza e é
isso que o fato está a passar de alguma
forma em portugal
nós vamos dizer vamos dizer o campeão da
frança
os famosos estão a substituir as novas
que todas nós vamos ter um país com a
maior densidade salários neste momento
no mano a mano
a nós no concurso acredita portugal
temos 18 mil candidaturas em r várias
áreas nós estamos de facto no início de
algo poderá ser verdadeiramente
revolucionário mas também estamos num
enquadramento global sobre essa função
temos as ferramentas da fabricação
digital a esta esta proposta do be
câmbio da moeda digital
nós temos a energia solar espanhol o
dólar mas permitem acabar eventualmente
com a adp
nós temos redes de comunicação
distribuídas nós temos a informação e
pelo local
nós temos a possibilidade da democracia
à direta
nós de fato temos agora uma função em
no meu discurso prévio de sua edição em
portugal em 2015 2015 nós deviam ser o
país mais vibrante europa lembra sou
feliz pois estamos crise vai aumentar a
minha cabeça que eu fui então
incrivelmente otimista
a nós sofremos uma crise financeira
precisa nos afetou a todos retornando à
minha empresa mais forte nós temos que
olhar para o futuro com otimismo e fato
todas estas tendências que o chifre dama
perto de salt mesmo agora sou mais
cautelosos
talvez 2025 somos o país mais grande
final para a resolução vai durar 10 anos
ok mas já existido que eu tô seguro não
será centralizada